germany's coronavirus infection numbers
are rising
rapidly the government is warning that
emergency rooms are filling up
but german political leaders have been
at odds over how to handle the crisis
a meeting of state and national leaders
scheduled for next monday has been
canceled
due to disagreements some states want to
loosen regulations while chancellor
angela merkel and others are calling
for tougher restrictions health minister
yen span today warned that the situation
in germany was serious and called for a
unified national approach
and tougher restrictions
in order to reduce these numbers we need
consistent and if possible nationwide
measures
many citizens also recognize the need to
break this wave of infections with
additional measures
many polls show this very clearly
at any rate citizens have a realistic
view of the situation and the gravity of
the situation
and the majority are in favor of
stricter rules a lockdown is needed to
break the current wave from the actual
valid suppression
let's talk about all of this with our
chief political correspondent melinda
crane hi melinda
as we heard the infection numbers in
germany are rising at the moment and
intensive care units are also filling up
so how serious
is the situation in germany
it's grave as the health minister and
also the head of the country's center
for disease control said today we are in
the midst of a third wave we're seeing
numbers edging close to the highest
numbers we have seen
in germany and both said that we are
also
seeing more and more serious cases
amongst younger people even even
teenagers
and children and as the head of the
center for disease control put it every
day we don't bring these numbers down is
a day that has
cost in human life and as you said
intensive care units increasingly
stretched also personnel
in intensive care units increasingly
burdened
so all of that makes it imperative to
act
meanwhile this comes as there's a battle
between state and national leaders on
how to proceed
and we're hearing that the german
government is trying to change that now
tell us more indeed uh there have been
battles because
according to the german constitution
health policies first and foremost in
the hands of the federal states
and there are wide variations among
different regions in germany we have
regions where
there are just 37 new cases per 100 000
uh residents
and others where there are nearly 300
new cases for the same number of
residents so
clearly a lot of variation now the heads
of the federal states
actually agreed on a plan in march that
was supposed to have
different levels of restrictions
depending on how how high the level of
infection
in specific regions were but there's a
lot of latitude for interpretation in
this plan
and some regions with high rates of
infection have still
tried to sort of find a middle ground
where like in berlin they test more
but they allow people still to go
shopping and they have only a
limited uh restriction on contact so the
federal government
has now said it wants to get a more
reliable
more automatic clearer plan for how to
proceed
based on levels of infection and it is
going to apparently
revise germany's federal law to make
that possible the interesting thing is
the federal states apparently have
agreed to this so we will see action
next week to put more control in the
hands of the federal government
and get a more reliable more automatic
plan for how to proceed our chief
political correspondent melinda crane
reporting there for us thank you so much
let's check in now some other
developments in the pandemic
india's coronavirus crisis continues to
worsen
record numbers were registered for the
third day in a row
japan has tightened restrictions on bars
restaurants
and events in tokyo and several other
areas amid a growing outbreak
just weeks after loosening them and the
city is due to host the olympic games in
july
and french medical authorities are
expected to recommend that people aged
under 55 who have already received one
dose of the astrazeneca vaccine
should get a different type of vaccine
as a second shot
new york city's cultural scene is seeing
some glimmers of hope
after more than a year of pandemic
restrictions the city's world-renowned
theaters
and concert halls probably will not open
before september
but with millions of residents now
vaccinated against the coronavirus
some venues are being allowed to reopen
and the excitement
is catching on new yorkers are finally
getting the opportunity again
to pursue one of their favorite pastimes
standing in life
i'm really excited for the city to
become the city again as we always knew
it would
it's pretty pretty exciting that you can
feel the feel the energy
okay they're not actually excited about
queuing up
but rather that after a year of zoom
meetings and elbow bumps
they're about to see a live show at one
of the city's most iconic entertainment
venues
the comedy cellar in manhattan's
greenwich village
the comedy seller has hosted nearly all
the trades greats over the decades
but like most venues it's been shuttered
for more than a year
now it's open again but at just 33
capacity
in accordance with new york's
regulations no covet 19 test is required
to enter
and neither are masks when seated the
club's owner is cautiously optimistic
the venue will stay
open now for good i don't expect things
to turn bad
now they're vaccinating people very very
quickly i think it's going to be okay i
hope it's okay you know
and if it's not i hope they'll shut us
down again you know they should do what
they need to do
despite rising case numbers the risk of
aerosols and virus variants
the comedians and the audience breathe a
sigh of relief
and yeah there will be jokes about the
pandemic
for the comedians for me it's cathartic
to talk about this stuff
to to just say what i was going through
and then i think for the audience it's
not just them identifying and relating
that is one level and that's huge too
but also just being
with other people physically being
around people around your peers
in some social setting that itself is
is important and gradually there are
more and more places for new yorkers to
do that
restaurants are allowed to host patrons
indoors at half capacity
most of the city's museums have been
open for months
and now major sports venues are also
welcoming fans again
madison square garden home to
professional sports teams like the new
york knicks and the new york rangers
is open again at 10 capacity but to get
in you have to have either a recent
negative cova test or
be fully vaccinated new york has just
launched a new app that will help
users prove their health status and that
authorities say
will make it easier for new yorkers and
visitors to access venues and activities
as the city slowly opens back up as
tourists are returning to new york
a so-called vaccination passport could
be an important tool to bring back major
attractions
like broadway most theaters here are
saying they won't reopen until all seats
can be filled
they're hoping sometime in the fall or
winter
but for now it's spring and new yorkers
are enjoying their newfound freedom
in the sun after a gloomy year in
isolation this is our first day
in one year coming back to downtown so
we are kind of
excited seeing so many people i'm a
musician i'm a music teacher
i went back to teaching in person a few
days a week after a year being on zoom
i don't think i'm ready to sit in a full
concert hall however i am going to give
a concert
in may in a one-third filled concert
hall so
it's i'm looking around here and my mind
is blown seeing how many people there
are i haven't seen this many people
in one spot in a year and a half
scientists are warning people not to let
their guard down
pandemic they say is far from over and
if cases keep rising
scenes like these could quickly again
become a thing
of the past